Grazie a tutti.
Allora, l'epanto 7 ottobre 1571, una battaglia che credo tutti hanno sentito nominare e che rischia anche nei tempi che stiamo attraversando di ridiventare in qualche modo un segnale, un punto di riferimento spesso evocato, magari anche a sproposito quando si parla di scontri di civiltà.
È una battaglia famosa e importante per tanti motivi. È una delle più grandi battaglie navali che si siano mai combattute nel Mediterraneo, per esempio. È una battaglia in cui si affrontano due flotte di circa 200 galere ciascuna.
Poi ci fermeremo a raccontare un po' più da vicino che cos'era una galera o galea, che si può dire in tutti e due i modi.
Due flotte di 200 galere ciascuna, una dell'impero ottomano e una delle potenze cristiane alleate, Venezia, Filippo II, re di Spagna, il Papa.
200 galere vuol dire che a bordo c'erano 50-60 mila uomini su ogni flotta.
Quindi in quel giorno, in quello specchio di mare, si affrontano e combattono più di 100 mila persone.
È una battaglia che, come è noto, viene di solito considerata epocale perché, in qualche modo, ferma o dà l'impressione di fermare la grande espansione dell'impero ottomano che si stava affermando come grande potenza del Mediterraneo.
Come si è arrivati a uno scontro del genere che abbia potuto avere, in un giorno solo, dei risultati così definitivi, apparentemente almeno?
Era cominciato tutto, in realtà, come una guerra tra Venezia e l'impero ottomano, l'impero turco.
Era cominciato un paio d'anni prima.
E più o meno intorno al 1569 che l'ambasciatore veneziano a Costantinopoli comincia a mandare dei messaggi un po' meno ottimistici del solito.
Era un uomo ottimista, si chiamava Marco Antonio Barbaro, e da quando era arrivato a Costantinopoli in genere diceva
ma no, qui più o meno va tutto bene, i turchi hanno altro per la testa, hanno altre guerre in mente, la pace con Venezia gli sta bene, così come stava benissimo ai veneziani.
E poi nel 1569 l'ambasciatore veneziano comincia a mandare dei rapporti in patria dove dice ma veramente nell'arsenale qui a Costantinopoli ci sono dei lavori in corso, più del solito.
Han preso più mano d'opera del solito.
Si dice che abbiano mandato in giro dei messaggeri del sultano con ordine di fabbricare nuove galere.
E io cerco di informarmi, mi assicurano che non ce l'hanno con noi, però si sa che in diplomazia non ci si può mai fidare fino in fondo.
Dopo un po' viene fuori invece che gli ottomani hanno una rivendicazione.
Vogliono chiedere a Venezia di cedere all'impero l'isola di Cipro.
Cipro era l'estremo lembo del dominio da mare veneziano.
È un'isola lontanissima da Venezia, come sapete, pienamente integrata nel contesto medio orientale.
Tanto lontana che durante appunto i negoziati che avvengono per questa richiesta dei turchi di cederla,
a un certo punto il Gran Vizir chiede all'ambasciatore veneziano ma avete fatto i conti?
Quanto è lontana quell'isola da Venezia?
E il barbaro dice beh sì, effettivamente sono duemila chilometri e poi lui stesso scrive a casa dicendo il Gran Vizir si è messo a ridere e ha detto che ne volete fare di quell'isola tanto lontana?
Datela a noi che starà meglio.
In realtà noi sappiamo che la popolazione greca di Cipro era profondamente scontenta del dominio veneziano,
che era un dominio di tipo feudale estremamente pesante con un assoggettamento durissimo dei contadini.
C'era uno scontro religioso fra i cristiani ortodossi di Cipro e i loro padroni cattolici italiani,
tanto che molti greci preferivano apertamente stare sopra il dominio turco,
dal momento che ai turchi non faceva gran differenza fra cattolici e ortodossi,
e lasciavano una relativa tolleranza, una relativa libertà di vita religiosa ai loro sudditi.
I turchi avevano ottimi motivi per volere Cipro,
tra l'altro Cipro era stata musulmana in passato,
Venezia aveva sempre riconosciuto una certa dipendenza dell'isola dal sultano,
tanto che pagava al sultano un tributo in monete d'oro,
in cambio del fatto di poter continuare ad avere Cipro.
Sta di fatto che a un certo momento il sultano decide che è ora di finirla,
e che Cipro sia restituita all'Islam,
anche perché finché appartiene a Venezia è una base di pirati cristiani,
i quali da lì vanno ad attaccare le navi che si spostano sulla rotta vitale dall'Egitto a Costantinopoli,
vanno ad attaccare le navi che portano i pellegrini musulmani alla Mecca,
le navi che portano il tributo dell'Egitto per il tesoro del sultano,
insomma c'è una tensione crescente,
alla fine i turchi dicono ai veneziani
«Ci sono molti motivi per cui Cipro deve tornare a noi,
datecela con le buone e saremo ottimi amici come siamo stati finora».
I veneziani hanno un sussulto di orgoglio e decidono di non cederla.
Decidono di affrontare la guerra.
Sono molto sicuri di sé,
si considerano ancora la più grande potenza navale del Mediterraneo,
e quando è chiaro che il sultano fa armare una flotta,
armano anche loro una flotta.
Per un mese, due, nella primavera del 1570,
è una gara tra l'arsenale di Istanbul e l'arsenale di Venezia
per chi riesce a mettere in mare più galere,
poi ci fermeremo abbastanza a lungo,
sulle enormi difficoltà che si affrontavano per creare queste flotte.
Fatto sta che la flotta veneziana esce in mare
con qualcosa come 150 galere
e si prepara ad andare nelle acque di Cipro
per impedire ai turchi di venire e di sbarcare,
naturalmente ci sono dei problemi logistici non da poco,
perché appunto Cipro dista 2000 km da Venezia
e una settantina dalla costa turca,
per cui già l'idea di impedire ai turchi di sbarcarci
non era così ovvia.
In realtà la flotta veneziana rimane ferma a lungo nell'Adriatico,
perché a bordo scoppia il tifo,
i rematori cominciano a morire,
i marinai, i soldati, i comandanti cominciano a morire,
si chiedono rinforzi,
a Venezia si continua a fabbricare nuove galere,
a reclutare nuova gente,
a mandarle alla flotta,
che sta a Zara,
poi si sposta a Corfu,
si avvicina lentamente al Levante,
ma intanto il tifo a bordo
provoca una devastazione tale
che l'ammiraglio non osa spingersi oltre.
Così i turchi
sbarcano a Cipro indisturbati,
conquistano rapidamente quasi tutta l'isola,
anche perché la popolazione locale
passa immediatamente dalla loro parte.
Ci sono storie che verrebbe la pena di raccontare,
di rappresaglie dei veneziani
che quando i primi villaggi
passano dalla parte dei turchi,
mandano fuori i soldati di notte
circondando un villaggio
e poi all'alba lo attaccano
e distruggono tutto
e ammazzano tutti
per rappresaglie appunto
contro questa tendenza dei contadini greci
ad accogliere a braccia aperta i turchi.
Fatto sta che
una sola piazzaforte, Famagosta,
continua a resistere,
ma il resto dell'isola ormai è conquistata.
E a Venezia qualcuno comincia a dire
visto che è andata così male
potremmo anche fare la pace,
forse siamo ancora in tempo
a rimetterci d'accordo,
perché questa guerra dà fastidio a molti.
I veneziani hanno enormi interessi commerciali
nell'impero ottomano
e la guerra a moltissimi dà fastidio.
Si comincia anche a negoziare sotto banco,
senza farlo troppo sapere,
perché le altre potenze europee
stanno a vedere cosa succede,
i veneziani hanno già la cattiva fama
di essere quelli
che si mettono troppo facilmente
d'accordo con i turchi.
Fatto sta che invece
a Roma il Papa Pio V
è convinto che questa sia la grande occasione
per fare una cosa
che ha sognato da molto tempo,
e cioè mettere d'accordo
le potenze cattoliche
per creare una grande coalizione
che finalmente sconfigga i turchi.
Papa Pio V si dà un grande affare,
negozia,
e riesce a fare questo miracolo,
mettere d'accordo
i veneziani e gli spagnoli
che si odiavano mortalmente,
che diffidano gli uni degli altri,
che non hanno nessuna voglia
ciascuno di spendersi
per aiutare l'altro,
tuttavia il Papa
alla fine con enorme insistenza
riesce a creare questa alleanza
che chiama, in buon augurio,
la Lega Santa.
È passato del tempo,
siamo ormai nel 1571,
primavera del 1571,
a Cipro c'è ancora
fama agosta assediata,
ma ormai è questione di settimane,
non resisterà a lungo,
il problema è che cosa
ha senso fare.
I turchi ormai
hanno conquistato Cipro,
ma, visto che è stato
così facile conquistarla,
la loro flotta
è di nuovo in mare,
anche nel 71,
con grandi ambizioni.
In tutto l'Occidente Mediterraneo
ci si chiede
dove andranno a colpire,
potrebbero sbarcare in Puglia,
come avevano fatto
a Otranto tanto tempo prima.
In realtà i turchi
sono gente sistematica,
hanno intenzione
di continuare a smantellare
il dominio navale veneziano,
e quindi la loro flotta
comincia con l'attaccare Creta,
che è un'altra colonia veneziana,
poi risale,
attacca le varie isole Ionie,
che sono tutte colonie veneziane,
Zante,
Cefalonia,
passa accanto a Corfu,
entra nell'Adriatico.
Quando la flotta turca
entra nell'Adriatico,
nell'estate del 71,
a Venezia
si spaventano abbastanza.
Noi abbiamo documentazione
molto ampia
di fortificazione
affrettata del Lido,
convocazione di milizie
dalla terraferma,
che devono accorrere a Venezia.
In realtà poi
il Nunzio Pontificio,
che è un ottimo informatore
per noi di quello che succede,
dice,
no,
questi signori veneziani,
i signori del governo,
non è che abbiamo veramente paura
che i turchi arrivino fin qui,
ma la popolazione è nel panico
e bisogna far vedere
che stiamo facendo qualcosa
per difendere la città.
Nel frattempo
si è firmata la Lega Santa,
e dunque
l'aspettativa di tutti
è che
alla flotta veneziana,
che si è faticosamente ripresa
dal tifo,
ma che ormai
è abbastanza debilitata,
vada ad aggiungersi
una grande flotta
del re di Spagna.
Il re di Spagna
è anche re di Napoli,
di Sicilia,
a Milano,
quindi è padrone
di quasi tutta Italia
in realtà,
e la sua potenza
finanziaria
e militare
è immensa.
Però nel Mediterraneo
fa fatica,
ha anche altri fronti
su cui combattere,
le Fiandre,
la guerra contro i protestanti,
il vecchio sogno
di invadere
l'Inghilterra di Elisabetta,
cosa che proverà
a fare qualche anno dopo
l'epoca dell'invincibile armada
che tutti ricordiamo.
Il re di Spagna
ha molte cose per la testa,
tuttavia accetta
di investire
denaro ed energie,
ne riparleremo,
per mettere in piedi
una flotta
che vada a unirsi
a quella veneziana.
Ci vuole del tempo.
Tutti stanno a vedere,
c'è una corrispondenza
fittissima
fra le capitali
del mondo mediterraneo,
gli ambasciatori,
i nunzi,
a Costantinopoli
si prendono notizie
e si sta a vedere
cosa succede,
se i cristiani
riusciranno
a riunire
una flotta
davvero in tempo
per andare
ad attaccare
quella ottomana
che nel frattempo
è entrata nell'Adriatico
e non si sa
che cosa voglia fare.
È una lotta
contro il tempo,
ci sono difficoltà
e ritardi enormi,
è faticosissimo
mettere in piedi
queste flotte,
manca tutto,
mancano i rematori,
mancano i remi,
alla fine
una flotta
pian piano
prende forma,
intanto i turchi
nell'Adriatico
devastano
le piazzaforti
veneziane,
conquistano
una dopo l'altra
gli ultimi porti
veneziani
sulla costa
albanese,
Montenegrina,
risalgono
fino ad assediare
Cattaro,
sono già abbastanza
avanti nell'Adriatico,
qualche squadra
di galeotte
pirate
fa delle scorrerie
fino a Chioggia
prendendo battelle
di pescatori
portando via
la gente,
in Italia
gli umori
sono ancora
estremamente tesi,
però lentamente
la grande flotta
cristiana
si sta radunando
a Messina
e quando finalmente
sono arrivati tutti
le galere spagnole
da Napoli,
da Genova,
le galere spagnole
da Barcellona,
le galere veneziane
da Creta,
da Corfu,
si sono finalmente
tutti radunati
e a questo punto
questa flotta salpa
e già abbastanza
avanti nell'anno
le galere
non navigano
d'inverno,
in autunno
devono rientrare
in porto
perché non sono
in grado
di tenere il mare
e tutti si chiedono
se questa flotta
che è stata messa
insieme con immensa
fatica
e con immensa spesa
farà davvero
qualche cosa.
Gli ottomani
ovviamente
nei loro informatori
agli ammiragli
della flotta
nell'Adriatico
arrivano le notizie,
la flotta cristiana
si è concentrata,
è a Messina,
è salpata
da Messina
e viene in Levante,
a questo punto
gli ammiragli turchi
decidono
che non è il caso
di restare nell'Adriatico
dove si può essere
imbottigliati
e cominciano
a ripiegare
verso il Levante
e intanto
scrivono disperatamente
a Costantinopoli
per avere ordini
perché a Costantinopoli
il sultano
e il gran vizir
fanno
quello che
in seguito
i teorici militari
hanno capito
che è uno sbaglio
cioè cercare
di dirigere
una flotta
dalla capitale,
dal ministero,
non bisogna farlo
e invece
allora
la cosa
non era così chiara.
Gli ammiragli
hanno degli ordini,
per cambiarli
devono aspettare
che da Costantinopoli
prendano atto
che la situazione
è cambiata,
scrivono
chiedendo
che facciamo
possiamo tornare
nei nostri porti
da Costantinopoli
gli scrivono
abbiamo saputo
che la flotta
dei cristiani
sta arrivando
vedete un po' voi
però se vengono
a darvi battaglia
l'onore
del nostro impero
e della fede
richiede
che accettiate
la battaglia.
Gli ammiragli
del sultano
sanno che la loro flotta
in tutta quell'estate
di operazioni
da Creta
in poi
si è logorata
gli uomini
sono stanchi
anche loro
hanno la malattia a bordo
hanno avuto tanti morti
tanta gente
che non ne può più
le galere
si sono logorate
hanno consumato
le munizioni
e settembre
fine settembre
sarebbe ora
di tornare in porto
effettivamente
vanno in porto
non tornano
a Costantinopoli
si fermano
in un porto
a metà strada
in Grecia
che è quasi tutto
dominio turco
in quell'epoca
in un posto
che molti di voi
avranno visto
perché basta
essere andati
col traghetto
e sbarcati a Patrasso
per avere visto
quello che è
l'imboccatura
del golfo di Lepanto
appena oltre Patrasso
appena oltre il ponte
che c'è adesso
c'è questo piccolo porto
di Lepanto
nel punto in cui
lo stretto
è particolarmente stretto
due forti turchi
lo controllano
ai due lati
lì la flotta ottomana
va a mettersi al sicuro
e scrivono a Costantinopoli
potremmo anche restare qua
tutto l'inverno
tutto sommato
intanto ci rafforziamo
ci riposiamo
reclutiamo nuovi soldati
nuovi rematori
ripariamo le galere
e da Costantinopoli
non arrivano nuovi ordini
e intanto la flotta cristiana
viene avanti
arriva a Corfu
il Mediterraneo è pieno
di spie
di informatori
tutti sanno tutto
anche se con grande lentezza
e ritardo
si sa che la flotta ottomana
ormai debilitata
dalla lunga campagna estiva
mentre la flotta cristiana
è fresca
nuova
non ancora combattuto
è stata appena messa insieme
è intatta
ecco
si sa che la flotta ottomana
si è ritirata a Lepanto
gli ammiragli cristiani
decidono di andare a vedere
se viene fuori
se i turchi
non venissero fuori
la flotta cristiana
potrebbe soltanto
incrociare avanti e indietro
e poi ormai sono i primi di ottobre
si tornerebbe a casa
qualcuno degli ammiragli cristiani
pensa fin dall'inizio
che sarebbe meglio
tornare a casa
e basta
per esempio
Gianandrea Doria
che comandava le galerie genovesi
di cui 11 erano
di sua proprietà
e non gli piaceva
rischiare di sciuparle
e di conseguenza
fin dall'inizio
aveva pensato
che tutto sommato
forse non ne verrà fuori niente
e sarà meglio
ecco
però
il mondo li guarda
tutto il mondo cattolico
sa
che è stato fatto
questo immenso sforzo
per andare a sfidare i turchi
come si fa
a tornare indietro
senza averci almeno provato
per cui la flotta cristiana
si porta
fino all'imboccatura
del golfo di Lepanto
e
gli ammiragli turchi
discutono
rileggono
i loro ordini
sono chiarissimi
il sultano ha detto
se la flotta dei miscredenti
verrà ad affrontarvi
dovete dare battaglia
per l'onore dell'impero
e della fede
e non osano disobbedire
escono
escono dal golfo
e lì
appunto
all'alba del 7 ottobre
le vedette
delle due flotte
avvistano
le vele
della flotta nemica
in avvicinamento
ci vogliono ore
ore e ore
perché si avvicinino
e quando sono finalmente
abbastanza vicine
comincia questa battaglia
che dura tutto il pomeriggio
e che cos'è una battaglia
di galere?
le galere sono
delle navi
che vanno sia a remi
sia a vela
immaginate un barcone
di 40 metri
basso
ha soltanto un ponte
e una stiva
ma non abitabile
la gente dorme sul ponte
è lungo 40 metri
e largo 5
è strettissimo quindi
ed è stracarico
di uomini
perché
la grandezza
della galera
quello che la rende
una nave
estremamente efficiente
per il Mediterraneo
è che appunto
può andare
sia a vela
sia a remi
nel Mediterraneo
ci sono spesso
bonacce improvvise
le navi da carico
stanno ferme
giorni e settimane
le navi da guerra
non possono permetterselo
vai a vela
quando puoi
per non far affaticare
troppo i rematori
che si stancano presto
e se sono stanchi
al momento in cui incontri
il nemico
non va bene
però ai rematori
quando c'è bisogno
di andare in velocità
quale che sia il vento
la galera può farlo
quindi è uno strumento
estremamente duttile
per farlo
e per andare veloce
ha bisogno
di un'enorme quantità
di rematori
su questi 40 metri
per 5
ci stanno stipati
come minimo
150 galeotti
che remano
più i marinai
che devono manovrare
le vele
il timone
e così via
ci sono alcuni
cannoni
sulla prua
e ci sono i cannonieri
che devono manovrarli
c'è il comandante
i suoi ufficiali
poi però
per combattere
questi cannoncini
non bastano
se due galere
si avvicinano
l'una all'altra
hanno il tempo
di tirare una salva
prima di venire dentro
e così la battaglia
in realtà si combatte
sparando all'impazzata
finché ci si avvicina
ma poi
la battaglia consiste
nel fatto che
le galere
si incastrano
le une nelle altre
si speronano
non per affondarsi
in genere
non riescono a affondarsi
speronandosi
ma perché le galere
sono anche cariche
di soldati
che appena si viene
a contatto
combattono
come se fossero per terra
con la differenza
che sulle galere
non si può arretrare
tanto perché si finisce
in mare
quindi sulla galera
40 metri per 5
oltre ai 150
ma a volte anche
200 rematori
oltre a una cinquantina
di uomini d'equipaggio
ci stanno anche
un centinaio di soldati
armati fino ai 20
che quando le galere
si incastrano
le une nelle altre
cominciano a combattere
ciascuno a suo modo
i turchi
hanno i giannizzeri
armati da archibugio
e poi hanno
la loro cavalleria
temutissima
sulla terraferma
che però sulle galere
non si porta i cavalli
naturalmente
che combatte con arco e frecce
sulle galere
non è l'ideale
ma questo hanno
la fanteria cristiana
è più forte
lo sanno tutti
è armata di archibugio
e di picca
sa manovrare
usando sia
la forza d'urto
della picca
sia la forza di fuoco
dell'archibugio
è corazzata
i soldati hanno tutti
il morione
la corazza
mentre i turchi
non usano
sostanzialmente
armature
insomma
ci sono molti buoni motivi
per cui i cristiani
sono andati
ad affrontare
la battaglia
dicendo
se loro vengono fuori
è la volta
che li sconfiggiamo
del resto
e lo dico
perché di solito
si dice che
l'Epanto
fu la battaglia
che infranse
il mito
dell'invincibilità
dei turchi
sul mare
in realtà
se uno legge
la corrispondenza
tra le corti cristiane
in quei mesi
tutti dicono
speriamo solo
che si arrivi alla battaglia
perché è la volta
che li annientiamo
come disse Papa Pio V
è la volta
che spezzeremo
le corna
a quell'indomita bestia
che sarebbe
il sultano
ed è quello
che succede
le due flotte
sono più o meno
della stessa forza
come numero di galere
forse i turchi
un po' meno
però i cristiani
sono freschi
e i turchi
sono logori
la fanteria cristiana
è sostanzialmente
meglio armata
di quella turca
le galere cristiane
portano di solito
più cannoni
di quelle turche
il risultato
è che
in questo immenso
macello
progressivamente
i turchi
vengono sconfitti
che vuol dire
che progressivamente
la fanteria cristiana
conquista
cattura
le galere
del nemico
catturare una galera
vuol dire
che sei andato avanti
combattendo
in mezzo al sangue
fino in fondo
macellando
tutti quelli
che ti trovi di fronte
oppure buttandoli
in mare
qualche duello
viene vinto
dai turchi
la grande maggioranza
dei duelli
sono vinti
dai cristiani
alla sera
la flotta turca
è distrutta
soltanto una piccola squadra
quella dei pirati algerini
che sono i migliori di tutti
i migliori marinai di tutti
la sanno lunga
riescono a scamparla
prendendo l'alto mare
e si portano via
anche qualche galera cristiana
catturata
ma il grosso della flotta
è annientato
moltissime galere
sono catturate
e trascinate poi via
quelle troppo malandate
vengono lasciate
a rompersi nel mare
poche affondano
per il fuoco
dei cannoni
e la gente a bordo
è quando si può
se i rematori dei turchi
erano schiavi cristiani
si cerca di liberarli
se ne liberano parecchie migliaia
ma come vedremo fra poco
i rematori non erano tutti schiavi
tutt'altro
il resto della gente
va a fondo
con le sue galero
viene massacrato
durante il combattimento
di quei 60.000 uomini
che c'erano a bordo
delle galere turche
appunto
qualche migliaio
che erano schiavi cristiani
si salvano
gli altri
sono andati
anche a bordo
delle galere cristiane
sono morti
e feriti dappertutto
i feriti
continueranno a morire
negli ospedali di Messina
e di Genova
per tutto l'inverno
però di fatto
la flotta cristiana
è intatta
ha perso pochissime galere
le 200 galere del nemico
sono svanite
non ci sono più
si può capire
che nel mondo cristiano
la notizia
di questa vittoria
che era stata
oltretutto
una vittoria
così accanitamente
cercata
e voluta
abbia suscitato
un'enorme
risonanza
uno dei fenomeni
più impressionanti
delle battaglie
di Lepanto
è il fatto
che nel giro
di pochi mesi
dopo la battaglia
viene pubblicata
dai tipografi
italiani
e spagnoli
e francesi
una marea
di instant book
diremmo noi oggi
di veri e propri libri
storie
oppure opuscoli
poesie
cartine
chiunque
in occidente
nel giro
di pochi mesi
può
se ha qualche soldo
in tasca
comprarsi
la stampina
con tutte le galere
che si sono affrontate
a Lepanto
con i nomi
di tutti i comandanti
dei turchi
più importanti
fatti prigionieri
e così via
è un esempio
impressionante
della potenza
della stampa
già in questo
maturo rinascimento
insomma
che è
il Tauro 500
ed allora in poi
Lepanto
non ha mai cessato
di risuonare
appunto
come
una data
memorabile
nella storia
del Mediterraneo
e in genere
nella storia
del confronto
tra il mondo cristiano
e il mondo
islamico
io per ora
vorrei fare
con voi
chi c'era già ieri
sa che questa
è la scommessa
oltre a raccontare
la battaglia
andare a vedere
un po' più da vicino
cosa ha voluto dire
per questi governi
mettere in piedi
queste flotte
per questi governi
e per i popoli
che gli ubbidivano
ben inteso
perché io vi ho raccontato
la battaglia di Lepanto
come si fa di solito
nella storia militare
ci sono delle flotte
e si affrontano
e come mai ci sono
delle flotte
e sono state suscitate
dal nulla
con la bacchetta magica
è stato facile
metterle insieme
o è stato difficile
queste flotte
costavano
ai governi
e ai popoli
degli sforzi
dei sacrifici
sia finanziari
sia umani
ma anche degli sforzi
di creatività
intellettuale
straordinari
è tutta un'altra storia
è una storia parallela
alle spalle
della storia vistosa
della campagna
dei suoi obiettivi strategici
della battaglia
del macello
della propaganda
ma è una storia
che vale allo stesso modo
la pena di fare
già costruire
una galera
è una cosa
che richiede
una sapienza
accumulata
straordinaria
mica tutti
la sanno costruire
ci sono pochi
artigiani
esperti
che sanno i segreti
che sanno esattamente
come bisogna tagliare
e piegare il legname
quale disegno
bisogna seguire
non ce n'è tanti
nel mondo mediterraneo
i turchi
in particolare
che hanno imparato
a usare le galere
dagli occidentali
e che ormai
le sanno usare bene
da un bel pezzo
però continuano
a essere affamati
di know-how
tecnologico
continuano ad accogliere
a braccia aperte
qualunque mastro
artigiano
che abbia voglia
di andare via
dall'occidente
magari perché
ha ammazzato qualcuno
ed è sotto processo
o magari perché
è rimasto disoccupato
ecco
chi ha voglia
di fare il viaggio
fino a Costantinopoli
sa che lì
verrà assunto
e pagato profumatamente
perché chi porta
con sé
le conoscenze tecnologiche
è un uomo
indispensabile
ci vuole il legname
sembra una stupidaggine
ci sono trattati
dell'epoca
che enumerano
tutti i tipi
di legname
necessari
per fare una galera
e per ogni singola
parte della galera
l'ideale
è un legno diverso
per i remi
ci vuole il faggio
per l'albero
ci vuole il pino
per la carena
ci vuole la quercia
per il ponte
ci vuole ancora
qualcos'altro
per carità
si può anche arrangiarsi
i veneziani
sostengono
che i turchi
sono un po' indietro
e quando fabbricano
le loro galere
non badano tanto
alla qualità
del legname
e lo prendono
anche fresco
anziché farlo stagionare
che sarebbe fondamentale
per cui i veneziani
sostengono
che le galere
dei turchi
sono un po' meno buone
tengono meno bene
l'acqua
col mare difficile
naufragano più facilmente
e comunque
non durano tanto
una galera
dovrebbe durare
15-20 anni
quelle dei turchi
dicono i veneziani
dopo 8-10 anni
si vede già
che sono state fatte
con un legno
non adatto
però non si sa mai bene
quanto questo sia vero
e quanto siano i pregiudizi
dei veneziani
che ne avevano tanti
in tante direzioni
ci vuole il legname
ci vogliono i boschi
d'alto fusto
uno penserebbe
che nel 500
non fosse un problema
era un problema
non tanto per il sultano
perché le province
intorno al mar nero
erano
sono tuttora
piene di foreste
quindi il sultano
quando voleva fabbricare
il naviglio
mandava ordini
ai cadì
di quelle zone
e le comunità locali
tagliavano il legname
lo portavano agli scali
lì si fabbricavano
le navi
le galere
senza troppe difficoltà
Venezia
non ha problemi
ma perché ha provveduto
fin dall'inizio
a tutelare i suoi boschi
Venezia
fin dall'inizio del 500
ha fatto leggi precise
che vietano
l'esportazione
di certi tagli
di legname
d'alto fusto
e che riservano
certe foreste
del cadore
per le esigenze
dell'arsenale
nessun privato
può acquistare
e utilizzare
certi tipi di albero
perché lo stato
si riserva
di averle a disposizione
il re di Spagna
che a questo
non ha mai pensato
in tempo
e che governa
un paese
che fin dal medioevo
per colpe
della pastorizia
ha visto
abbattere le sue foreste
per fare pascoli
per le pecore
il re di Spagna
ha dei problemi
serissimi
la Spagna
già a quell'epoca
è quasi completamente
deforestata
il re di Spagna
fa fabbricare
le sue galere
in grande maggioranza
a Napoli
a Genova
a Messina
perché almeno lì
ci sono ancora
le foreste
specialmente quelle
della Sila
dove c'è
il legname
d'alto fusto
necessario
le poche galere
che fa fabbricare
nell'unico arsenale
che ha in Spagna
a Barcellona
sono veramente poche
e si fa sempre
una gran fatica
a completarle
io vi ho detto
che nell'estate
del 71
stanno tutti lì
col fiato sospeso
perché i turchi
sono nell'Adriatico
e la flotta cristiana
non riesce a radunarsi
perché la squadra
di Barcellona
prima di partire
per tanti motivi
ma anche perché
la squadra di Barcellona
prima di partire
e salpare per Messina
scopre di essere
a corto di remi
e non c'è
in tutta la Spagna
legname adatto
per fabbricare
i remi delle galere
che sono remi immensi
un unico remo
usato da tre o quattro
o anche cinque
galeotti
iperbanco
non c'è
li ordinano a Napoli
e finché non arriva
questa nave da carico
da Napoli a Barcellona
con i remi
per le galere
la squadra spagnola
non può salpare
dunque
cominciamo già a vedere
stiamo parlando soltanto
della fabbricazione
della galera
poi una volta fabbricata
la galera resta
c'è il problema
dell'equipaggio
della ciurma
ed è un problema enorme
vi ho detto
quanto gente ci vuole
le galere
diversamente
dalle navi
che si fabbricano
oggi
oggi uno fabbrica
una nave
e la nave
sta in mare
di solito
finché
continua a durare
opera
le galere
invece venivano
fabbricate
e poi tenute
in secca
quando ce n'era
bisogno
si provvedeva
a reclutare
la ciurma
di rematori
e l'equipaggio
e a metterla
in mare
per i mesi estivi
tanto poi comunque
si sapeva
che per l'autunno
avrebbero dovuto
tornare in porto
e a quel punto
si licenziavano tutti
con enorme risparmio
per l'erario
si tiravano in secca
le galere
e si aspettava
che ce ne fosse
di nuovo bisogno
questo poteva
anche essere
un vantaggio
quando a Venezia
si sparge la voce
che il turco
sta armando
e le autorità
veneziane
decidono
che guerra o no
intanto è meglio
mettere in mare
la flotta
nell'arsenale
di Venezia
ci sono 100 galere
pronte
smontate
bisogna soltanto
rimontarle
e le maestranze
dell'arsenale
sono in grado
di farlo
in un paio
di mesi
sostanzialmente
quindi una flotta
dal punto di vista
degli scafi
sorge dal nulla
in questo modo
possono restare
per anni
in secca
l'arsenale
di Venezia
è a quell'epoca
il più grande
impianto industriale
del mondo europeo
e mediterraneo
è un impianto
dove c'è spazio
per conservare
e se necessario
lavorare
più di 100 galere
appunto
è un luogo
dove possono lavorare
contemporaneamente
parecchie migliaia
di artigiani
se ce n'è bisogno
non è un impianto
industriale
nel senso nostro
perché questi artigiani
non sono assunti
a tempo pieno
sono gli artigiani
veneziani
i carpentieri
i calafati
i remaioli
e così via
che vengono chiamati
in arsenale
quando ce n'è bisogno
però il governo
veneziano
è talmente disposto
a spendere
per essere sicuro
di avere sempre
a disposizione
la manodopera
che ha degli accordi
con le corporazioni
artigiane
che garantiscono
a questi artigiani
dei privilegi
inauditi
altrove
in Europa
al tempo
i carpentieri
i calafati
i fabbricanti
di remi
di Venezia
hanno il privilegio
che ognuno
sta alla sua bottega
e lavora
ma se un giorno
non ha lavoro
ha diritto
ad andare all'arsenale
e riscuotere
la paga di quel giorno
che ci sia bisogno
di lui
o che non ci sia bisogno
in questo modo
però
la Repubblica
sa di avere
il completo controllo
sulle sue forze artigiane
sono tutti schedati
elencati
registrati
e quando c'è bisogno
devono mollare la bottega
e venire a lavorare
alle galerie dello Stato
nell'arsenale
dicevo che l'arsenale di Venezia
è il più grande impianto
industriale
del Mediterraneo
e dell'Europa
il secondo
è l'arsenale di Costantinopoli
che è stato messo in piedi
dai turchi
a imitazione
di quello veneziano
con delle differenze
con anche dei miglioramenti
e perfino più grande
ci sono qualcosa
come 200 capannoni
in ognuno dei quali
si può lavorare
a una galera
se ce n'è bisogno
i turchi sono sempre
a corto
di mano d'opera specializzata
ma la fanno venire
volentieri dall'Occidente
pagandola molto bene
quando si può
la fanno venire
dai loro possedimenti
greci
i greci sono un popolo
marinaro
diversamente dai turchi
quindi hanno
un'esperienza
accumulata
non c'è
a Costantinopoli
questa regola
che gli artigiani
anche se non c'è bisogno
di loro
possono venire
e farsi pagare
lo stesso
e gli ambasciatori
veneziani trovano
che è una cosa
molto saggia
ci sono lettere
degli ambasciatori
che dicono
non è come da noi
che ci sveniamo
per pagare
tutta questa gente
anche quando
non serve a niente
il sultano
li chiama
quando ne ha bisogno
e vengono
naturalmente
ecco
stiamo ancora
sempre parlando
degli scafi
del fatto
di rimontare
le galerie
già esistenti
rimetterle in mare
vedere se tengono
ancora bene
e una volta
che hai lo scafo
e lo devi riempire
di equipaggio
e di soldati
come si fa
un'idea un po' diffusa
è quella
che fossero essenzialmente
schiavi
quelli che remavano
sulle galerie
in realtà non è così
la cosa è molto più complessa
gli schiavi c'erano
perché
nel Mediterraneo
di quell'epoca
l'impero ottomano
da una parte
e l'impero spagnolo
dall'altra
si consideravano
ufficialmente nemici
erano nemici
in perpetuo
non hanno mai fatto
un trattato
un accordo di pace
non avevano
non si scambiavano
ambasciatori
di conseguenza
in mare
quando
una galera
del sultano
catturava
un'imbarcazione
appartenente
al re di Spagna
e quindi
un'imbarcazione spagnola
ma anche italiana
naturalmente
del sud
automaticamente
si riduceva
in schiavitù
l'equipaggio
la stessa cosa
facevano naturalmente
i cristiani
le galerie
del re di Spagna
le galerie di Napoli
di Sicilia
le galerie
dei cavalieri
di Malta
quando intercettavano
in mare
un qualunque
vascello
musulmano
non necessariamente
da guerra
anche i mercantili
anzi soprattutto
si cercavano i mercantili
oltre a prendere tutto
tutti quelli che erano a bordo
venivano immediatamente
fatti schiavi
e messi ai remi
esistevano gli schiavi
per via di questa
ostilità
inveterata
perché
naturalmente
né i cristiani
né i musulmani
potevano
in base alla loro legge
ridurre in schiavitù
i correligionari
i musulmani
potevano avere
soltanto schiavi cristiani
i cristiani
potevano avere
soltanto schiavi musulmani
quindi gli schiavi
c'erano
Venezia
che si sforzava
di restare in pace
con i turchi
che è restata
in pace con i turchi
per gran parte
della sua storia
che aveva un ambasciatore
stabile a Costantinopoli
cosa che il re Filippo
non avrebbe mai fatto
il re Filippo
aveva due o trecento spie
a Costantinopoli
e più volte
mandava assassini
per cercare di avvelenare
il sultano
ma ambasciatori
non li aveva
Venezia
che con i turchi
cercava di restare in pace
aveva degli accordi
con il sultano
per cui a bordo
delle sue galere
schiavi musulmani
non ne teneva
e dunque
sulle galere veneziane
schiavi non ce n'è
su quelle turche
e su quelle spagnole
ce ne sono
ma non erano tanti
lo sappiamo dai prezzi
i prezzi degli schiavi
erano molto alti
in quel momento
vuol dire che complessivamente
la pirateria
da una parte
e dall'altra
non forniva
quella gran quantità
di mano d'opera
e lì
lì sono questioni economiche
se gli schiavi
costano troppo
intanto vuol dire
che non ce ne sono proprio
e poi comunque
non è il modo migliore
di armare le galere
sulla flotta turca
c'erano forse
20 o 30 galere
a Lepanto
armate di schiavi
le flotte
del re di Spagna
avevano schiavi a bordo
ma su ogni galera
li mescolavano
con altri tipi
di rematori
e allora
se non ci sono gli schiavi
come si fa?
la grande soluzione
che trovano
i governi dell'epoca
è
come dice la parola stessa
di condannare
alla galera
le persone
condannate
per reati comuni
e in quel momento
che il nome galera
che indicava
un tipo di nave
passa a indicare
anche la prigione
si condannano
alla galera
sono i forzati
tutti i tipi
di delinquenti
è uno straordinario affare
anziché
doverli mantenere
nelle prigioni
del governo
li si mette
a remare
sulle galere
dello Stato
sono una presenza
comune
in tutto l'occidente
in questi secoli
i forzati
che dopo essere stati
condannati dai tribunali
della loro città
vengono condotti
in convoglio
in catene
al porto più vicino
dove vengono
imbarcati
sulle galere
e messi al remo
e lì di nuovo
incatenati
lo fanno anche
i turchi
che imitano
questa cosa
si rendono conto
che è utile
e anche i turchi
cominciano a stabilire
che per molte pene
i cadì
possono sostituire
la detenzione
o le pene corporali
con un certo periodo
di galera
chi va in galera?
tutti
dal piccolo delinquente
che si è preso
un paio d'anni
perché ha rubato
una pagnotta
all'assassino
l'uxoricida
l'eretico
fra i galeotti
si trova di tutto
la gran parte
sono povera gente
naturalmente
ma ci si trova anche
il sacerdote
che si è spretato
e che poi è stato ripreso
dall'inquisizione
ci si trova
l'intellettuale
che però appunto
ha ammazzato la moglie
in un attacco di gelosia
ci si trova di tutto
c'è in Cervantes
nel Don Quixote
una grande scena
in cui Don Quixote
incontra appunto
un convoglio di forzati
siamo in Spagna
che vanno a Barcellona
per essere imbarcati
sulle galere
e li interroga
e c'è la gente più diversa
tra questi forzati
perfino nei paesi
che non tengono
flotte di galere
i forzati
vengono condannati
e poi vengono venduti
ai governi
che ne hanno bisogno
così per esempio
un piccolo stato italiano
che non avesse
un accesso al mare
però condannava
alla galera
e poi vendeva
a Genova
o al Papa
i suoi forzati
vendeva vuol dire
ecco qua un forzato
condannato a 5 anni
ci pagate 10 ducati
all'anno
ve lo lasciamo
naturalmente
si preferivano
i forzati
come si diceva allora
di buona condanna
cioè quelli
con condanne lunghe
gli ammiragli
gli protestavano
quando gli mandavano
gente condannata
a un anno
in un anno
fanno appena
in tempo
a imparare il mestiere
gli ammiragli
chiedevano ai tribunali
di essere severi
e mandare appunto
il termine corrente
nelle loro lettere
forzati di buona condanna
5 anni
10 anni
a vita
meglio ancora
quelli sono gente
che renderà
imparerà il mestiere
e saranno i migliori
peraltro
gli ammiragli
scrivono anche
ai tribunali
dicendo
questo uso
di interrogare
i sospetti
con la tortura
della corda
che è universalmente
diffuso
nell'Europa
del rinascimento
dell'età moderna
la tortura
della corda
consiste nel fatto
che ti legano
le mani dietro
e poi ti tirano su
con una carrucola
e poi ti lasciano
ricadere bruscamente
a mezz'aria
e fa molto male
evidentemente
non si rischia di morire
quindi è una tortura
perfetta per i tribunali
ma
se va male
ci si può slogare
le spalle
e comunque
per un bel po' di tempo
non si è più in grado
di remare
bene
ci sono ammiragli
che scrivono ai tribunali
dicendo
fareste meglio
a non usare più
la tortura della corda
perché i forzati
che ci mandate
sono rovinati
da questa tortura
e dunque i forzati
ma anche i forzati
non sono mai abbastanza
noi sappiamo
che dappertutto
c'è un'ansia
di trovare gente
da mettere ai remi
e non bastano
i tribunali
si danno da fare
si ingegnano
condannano
ma comunque
nessuna galera
può essere armata
soltanto con forzati
e allora come si fa?
e qui la cosa
cambia molto
a seconda degli stati
Venezia
che per antica tradizione
una potenza marinara
ha elaborato
nel corso
dei secoli
le sue abitudini
le sue consuetudini
le sue leggi
Venezia
usa un sistema
estremamente semplice
è dovere
di tutti quanti
se ce n'è bisogno
andare a remare
in galera
in altre parole
il governo
può pretendere
dalla società civile
la fornitura
di reclute
da mettere a remare
naturalmente
non incatenati
come forzati
li si mette a remare
sono cittadini
che prestano
il loro servizio
per quell'anno
quando ce n'è bisogno
e tutto questo
viene elaborato
con attenzione
con negoziati
con le comunità
la città di Venezia
deve fornire
10.000 rematori
questi 10.000 rematori
li forniscono
innanzitutto
le corporazioni
ma anche
le confraternite religiose
le grandi scuole
di Venezia
una grande confraternita
che ha
decine di migliaia
di adepti
negozia col governo
la fornitura
di un certo numero
di reclute
per il remo
le comunità
di terraferma
devono fornirle
quando ce n'è bisogno
Vicenza
Verona
e poi
tocca alle autorità locali
cercare ovviamente
sorteggiare
cercare volontari
se ci sono
a volte ci sono anche
la battaglia di Lepanto
è combattuta
in epoca di disoccupazione
di carestia
i volontari
si trovano anche
nei luoghi
abituati
al mare
come Venezia
i turchi
fanno la stessa cosa
il sultano
ha accordi precisi
con i suoi sudditi
io garantisco
la pace
garantisco a ognuno
la libertà
di praticare
la sua religione
ma in cambio
tutti
mi devono aiutare
quando ne ho bisogno
ogni comunità
che sia musulmana
o che sia cristiana
perché l'impero ottomano
possiede la Grecia
e i Balcani
è popolato
per metà
da cristiani
ogni comunità
quando ce n'è bisogno
deve fornire i rematori
al palazzo di Topkapi
a Istanbul
dove ha sede
il sultano
e il governo
ci sono i registri
con gli elenchi
di tutti i villaggi
dell'impero
ciascuno dei quali
quanti abitanti ha
e quindi
quanti rematori
deve fornire
e ogni anno
si va a vedere
l'anno scorso
questo villaggio
li ha già forniti
quest'anno
sarà esentato
ma sta di fatto
che ogni volta
che il sultano
mette in mare
una flotta
questo vuol dire
molti mesi prima
mandare gli ordini
alle autorità locali
in tutto l'impero
e reclutare i rematori
e poi questi
in convoglio
mantenuti
con denaro
fornito dal governo
lentamente
arrivano
ci mettono dei mesi
magari a piedi
a Costantinopoli
e prendono servizio
con la flotta
il re di Spagna
questa cosa
non la può fare
perché il re di Spagna
nei suoi regni
ha degli accordi
diversi con il paese
non è ancora
l'epoca dell'assolutismo
questa
non è ancora l'epoca
in cui un re può dire
allo stato sono io
e faccio quello
che voglio
il re Filippo
è re
perché i suoi vari paesi
i suoi vari regni
di Castiglia
di Aragona
di Murcia
di Granada
di Napoli
di Sicilia
lo hanno riconosciuto
come re
e hanno dei privilegi
precisi da rispettare
non può
costringere i sudditi
ad andare in galera
quando si prepara
la flotta per l'epanto
i veneziani
continuano a dire
ma noi non capiamo perché
sarebbe così facile
e ci sono dei carteggi
come dire
anche risentiti
in cui il re di Spagna
e i suoi ministri
dicono
no nei nostri regni
questo non si fa
mandare la gente
in galera per forza
lo faranno i veneziani
lo faranno i turchi
ma noi
qui negli stati
del re cattolico
non lo possiamo fare
possiamo prendere
dei volontari
è il massimo
che possiamo fare
ora i volontari
c'è un termine specifico
per indicarli
nell'italiano
di quei secoli
li chiamano
il buona voglia
a Venezia
ci sono anche
perché a Venezia
appunto
sulle galere
gli schiavi
non remano
i forzati
cominciano a usarli
a un certo punto
di malavoglia
ma li tengono separati
ci sono delle galere
apposta per i forzati
quindi su una normale
galera veneziana
chi rema
sono tutti liberi cittadini
magari presi
come reclute
per forza
obbligati
insomma
per coscrizione
però comunque
sempre liberi cittadini
che sanno che
alla fine dell'anno
se ne tornano a casa loro
che vengono pagati
regolarmente
dunque a Venezia
è un mestiere
che si può fare
remare in galera
è il mestiere più infimo
è il mestiere dei poveracci
rende pochissimo
sono pagati
veramente poco
perché ce ne vogliono
così tanti
che non si può
pagarli bene
tuttavia sono pagati
e a Venezia
si trovano anche
dei volontari
poi appunto
negli anni di carestia
se ne trovano di più
negli anni di disoccupazione
ma nel resto
d'Italia
e di Spagna
dove la consuetudine
col mare è minore
dove non c'è
questo orgoglio
di essere una potenza marinara
tutte le testimonianze
ci dicono
che andare a finire
in galera
è la peggior disgrazia
che può capitare
a un poveraccio
e chi ci va a finire?
proprio quello
che si è bevuto tutto
che è rimasto
senza neanche
la camicia addosso
la moglie
lo ha piantato
è lì che dorme
per strada
disperato
si arruola
in galera
il vagabondo
che dopo un po'
la polizia gli dice
senti
o sgombri
o comunque
ti imbarchi
e ti fai il suo turno
in galera
e il vagabondo
tutto sommato
se lo fa il suo turno
volontario
anche lui
ufficialmente
pagato
questi buona voglia
sono difficili da trovare
tant'è vero
che quando si trovano
si fa di tutto
per tenerli
ci sono lettere
di comandanti
di galere
di quest'epoca
che dicono
molto chiaramente
che si cerca
di imbrogliarli
sulla paga
e comunque
di fare in modo
che si indebitino
gli dai un anticipo
poi gli dai un altro
poi gli addebiti
il berrettino rosso
che gli hai fornito
gli addebiti
la camicola
che gli hai fornito
gli addebiti
il rancio
quando sono passati
i sei mesi
per cui il poveraccio
si era ingaggiato
va a vedere
sui libri
e si scopre
no tu ci devi ancora
due ducati
che fai
remi anche quest'altro anno
e questo è proprio
teorizzato ufficialmente
dai comandanti di marina
come il sistema
per tenersi
i rematori
talmente ce n'è bisogno
talmente c'è quest'ansia
di averli
nel regno di Napoli
c'è un sistema
ancora più
straordinario
di reclutare gente
quando bisogna
a tutti i costi
trovare rematori
per le galere del re
si mette un banchetto
al porto
dietro il banchetto
c'è un segretario
con un mucchietto
di ducati d'oro
e invita
non dico
venghino venghino
signori
ma praticamente
lo stile è questo
invita
chi vuole
a provare
a giocarsi
la fortuna
i soldi
oppure
l'imbarco in galera
secondo di come va a finire
quando ha trovato due poveracci
che ci stanno
impresta a ciascuno
sei ducati
che sarebbero la paga
dei sei mesi di servizio
impresta a ciascuno
sei ducati
poi loro se li giocano
ai dadi
quello che vince
prende i sei ducati
dell'altro
i suoi li restituisce
al segretario
quindi ha pagato
il suo debito
e se ne va
con i sei ducati
che ha guadagnato
quello che ha perso
ha ricevuto
in prestito
dal re
sei ducati
e non li può restituire
e di conseguenza
si fa il suo anno di galera
e in questo modo
vengono armate
le galere cristiane
che vanno ad affrontare
quelle ottomane
a Lepanto
questo è il genere
di umanità
che c'era a bordo
di quelle galere
questo è il genere
di impatto
che questo sforzo
bellico ha
non soltanto appunto
sui governi
ma sulle società
è uno sforzo enorme
anche perché pensate
a quei 50 o 60 mila uomini
che erano a bordo
delle galere
dell'impero ottomano
quando tutto
l'impero ottomano
non aveva probabilmente
più di 20 milioni
di abitanti
sono percentuali
strabilianti
rispetto alla popolazione
complessiva
si capisce
che anche se il Mediterraneo
era abbastanza popoloso
nell'insieme
questa fame di uomini
fosse sentita
continuamente
da tutti
Papa Pio V
l'anno prima di Lepanto
quando già i cristiani
avevano cominciato
a mettere insieme
un po' di flotta
aveva armato
delle galere sue
o meglio
se le era fatte
imprestare dai veneziani
gli scafi
aveva fatto
un regolare contratto
i veneziani
lo avevano imbrogliato
gli avevano fornito
gli scafi peggiori
che avevano
senza fornire
tutti gli armeggi
i remi
che avevano dovuto
poi hanno detto
no veramente
da contratto
siete voi
che dovete metterli
il Papa si era
molto seccato
anche
e comunque
per armare queste galere
si era lasciato
trascinare dai consiglieri
e aveva chiesto
ai principi
dello stato
della chiesa
ai colonna
agli orsini
ai grandi nobili
ai grandi latifondisti
di fornire
un certo numero
di loro contadini
per remare
su queste galere
dando ordine
come capo
dello stato pontificio
che chi veniva
selezionato
doveva
prestare servizio
ebbene
poi aveva avuto
gli scrupoli di coscienza
dopo aver fatto
questa cosa
ci sono lettere
di cardinali
che ci dicono
e il Papa
non ha mai digerito
questa cosa
che ha dovuto fare
o che gli hanno fatto fare
ma non la vuole fare più
costringere la gente
ad andare in galera
non si deve fare
e dunque vedete
l'ampiezza di questioni
anche a questo punto
non soltanto
economiche
sociali
politiche
etiche
perfino
che entrano in ballo
quando si deve mettere
in campo una flotta
è facile
quando si fa
la storia militare
dire appunto
sono state messe
in mare
200 galere
cosa questo
ha voluto dire
per tutti
è una cosa
che è più facile
invece
dimenticarsi
e abbiamo parlato
naturalmente
soltanto dei rematori
che sono l'elemento
più importante
perché appunto
ce ne vogliono tantissimi
e i soldati
i soldati
si reclutano anche loro
sul momento
quando ci vogliono
non esistono eserciti
permanenti
in quest'epoca
quando si deve fare
la guerra
qualunque guerra
e nel caso specifico
quando ci vogliono
i soldati
da imbarcare
sulle galere
ebbene
è tutto un movimento
di addetti ai lavori
di uomini d'affari
di imprenditori
militari famosi
grandi nobili
specializzati
in questo tipo
di lavoro
possono essere
dei Gonzaga
dei da Correggio
dei Colonna
i quali
quando un governo
ha bisogno di uomini
si offrono
io sono in grado
di reclutare
duemila uomini
se c'è bisogno
si analizza la proposta
ci si mette d'accordo
il governo
sborsa
quei cinque
sei
diecimila
ducati
dopodiché
l'imprenditore
che è uomo conosciuto
nell'ambiente
che ha già fatto
questa cosa
in passato
che ha grandi feudi
grandi possedimenti
con tanta gente
che lavora per lui
si dà da fare
e recluta
i suoi uomini
manda in giro
ufficiali
i tamburini
a dire
i giovanotti
che hanno voglia
di provarci
e di guadagnare
dei soldi
e di vedere
il mondo
vengano
e i giovanotti
ci sono
i disoccupati
gli ubriaconi
i poverazzi
o semplicemente
quelli che davvero
hanno voglia
di vedere il mondo
arrivano
si scartano
quelli malati
quelli troppo giovani
oppure se c'è
un gran bisogno
di gente
e l'affare è grosso
si prendono anche quelli
sperando che poi
i funzionari del governo
che devono fare il controllo
non se ne accorgano
che ci sono troppi zoppi
troppi ragazzi
ancora con la barba
che non spunta
e così via
li si arma
con quel denaro
che il governo
ha fornito
il reggimento
è pronto
nel giro di poche settimane
un imprenditore abile
ben finanziato
dal governo
è in grado
di reclutare
i suoi mille
duemila uomini
in Italia
si reclutano soprattutto
nelle zone più povere
naturalmente
in montagna
per esempio
gli stessi comandanti militari
sono spessissimo
provenienti
da quelle parti
se si va a vedere
chi erano i militari italiani
che hanno tentato
di difendere Cipro
contro i turchi
e beh si vede
che sotto i comandanti veneziani
i capitani
delle compagnie
erano poi tutti
marchigiani
erano magari
di Ancona
di Fermo
oppure Umbri
da zone che
tradizionalmente
appunto
avevano
gente disoccupata
che cercava lavoro
e che trovava
quel lavoro lì
i turchi
facevano
tutt'altro
i turchi
avevano
un sistema
straordinario
per mettere in campo
delle truppe
i giannizzeri
la truppa scelta
e la forza
più efficace
più efficiente
meglio addestrata
che il sultano
avesse
in mano
anche se si dice
che le compagnie
destinate alle galere
erano le peggiori
perché ai soldati
tutto sommato
combattere per mare
non è mai piaciuto tanto
i turchi
per avere i giannizzeri
ogni qualche anno
mandavano degli ufficiali
dei giannizzeri
nei Balcani
a visitare
tutti i villaggi cristiani
sudditi del sultano
cercavano
in ogni villaggio
qualche ragazzino
promettente
e avevano il diritto
di reclutarlo
per il sultano
ovviamente
lì possiamo immaginare
tutto il livello
di contrattazioni
bustarelle
e così via
per non far prendere
mio figlio
prendi piuttosto
quell'altro
o certe volte
anche invece
fai prendere mio figlio
perché almeno
esce dalla miseria
e va a Costantinopoli
a fare una nuova vita
fatto sta che
ogni pochi anni
arrivano a Costantinopoli
centinaia
se non migliaia
di ragazzini cristiani
i quali arrivati
a Costantinopoli
vengono convertiti
d'ufficio all'Islam
e arruolati
nel corpo dei giannizzeri
attraversano
un lungo addestramento
molto duro
vengono affidati
a dei contadini
che li allevano
a fare il contadino
intanto gli insegnano
il turco
e così via
dopodiché
quando sono maturi
tornano a Costantinopoli
ed entrano nel corpo
i giannizzeri
che sono la forza scelta
del sultano
ce ne erano
quattromila
probabilmente
a Leipanto
sulle galere turche
i migliori
quelli che andavano
più filo da torcere
erano tutti
fedelissimi
combattenti
del sultano
e musulmani
ortodossi
che però
erano nati cristiani
ed erano stati cristiani
da bambini
prima di essere presi
in questo ingranaggio
anche lì
ne potremmo raccontare
tante altre
noi abbiamo più il tempo
di farlo
quello che mi sembrava
importante fare
era
come dire
dare questo suggerimento
c'è sempre una storia
che è quella appariscente
e quella degli avvenimenti
che sono appassionanti
da raccontare
che sono vistosi
che sono quelli che arrivano
all'opinione pubblica
ma se si vuole capire
come funziona la storia
è poi sempre necessario
andare sotto
e andare a vedere
le infinite cose
che a noi sfuggono
ma che ai protagonisti
non sfuggivano
perché il re Filippo
passava le notti
con i suoi segretari
a scrivere a Napoli
perché arrivassero i remi
finalmente
a calcolare
quanti forzati
erano stati forniti
dai tribunali
del regno
quell'anno
a decidere
se mandare sulle galere
i moriscos
che si erano ribellati
anche se poi
gli aveva concesso la grazia
e allora si vergognava un po'
a mandarli sulle galere
infatti poi non li manda
le notti
passavano a fare questo
pianificare
la politica
e la guerra
voleva dire
fare i conti
con tutti questi problemi
e se noi vogliamo capire
quello che succedeva
al di là della propaganda
ecco
è necessario andare in profondità
e vedere queste cose
grazie